hey everybody and welcome to a
conclusive wild ride with steo that's
how science works you got a hypothesis
you end up with a conclusion and boy we
have a bunch of those I'm telling you
this Man Neil degrass Tyson sat us down
and schooled us frankly he made fun of
us too and it was hilarious we loved
every minute of it and I got a little
dose of my own medicine this one is wild
indeed let's get into
it ladies and gentlemen Neil degrass
Tyson there it was supposed to be
Applause or something if you want to
announce it that way at least put in an
Applause track or something um people
are applauding at home oh at home okay
all right hey we uh we just always do
you know I I start to wonder too if um
if it's Politically Incorrect to begin
by it
is just if your intuition leaves you
wondering if it is Politically Incorrect
it is the answer is yes okay but go on
uh if it's if it's wrong to say ladies
and gentlemen yeah I don't say that
anymore for example in my public talks
wow but when they introduce me I say
just say
humanoids because why specify gender at
all you just all humans who are out
there so say yeah so when I'm introduced
they have explicit instructions to say
instead of ladies and gentlemen which
has a ring to it right a historical sort
of Legacy feel to it it's just please
welcome to the stage Neil degrass Tyson
and anyone who hears that is going to be
human and react and so why specify I
like that man I think that I'm done
saying ladies and gentlemen you want to
give this one another shot no I think
that was fantastic you just retired
ladies and gentl yeah yeah I mean why
not people of the universe thank you
citizens of Earth
all right I'm going to figure it out I'm
going to come up with it but thank you
for being here it's a great honor sure
sure and uh I mean by the way just a
thing about being specific I remember as
a kid looking at uh a bottle of wierer
sauce right and was it's an odd sauce
it's not ketchup it's not mustard what
do you do with I was a kid and I read
what you do with it and it says it's
good on fish chops steaks soups and
think well that's everything I'd be
eating so so why are they listing
everything I might be eating because
you're having something for dinner and
you're going to see that in the list and
you're going to say oh this is just for
me interesting so then they're really
talking to your needs in that moment
they can't just say put it on everything
because then that's not specific enough
so that I was learning how advertising
tries to affect you and a general
statement that could be just as true is
not as potent you need to be broadly
specific bro so if you say ladies and
gentlemen and someone is neither you're
not speaking to them right but really
you want to speak to them so P now does
did the reverse engineer that philosophy
to write people's horoscopes well people
who write horoscopes you know it's a big
business I'm still uh amazed that that's
going on right there no Alchemists
running around you know you know Alchemy
predated chemistry and astrology
predated modern astronomy and as physics
so you would think they would just
dissolve away but astrology is still
with this and last I check there's not
much Alchemy going on out there yeah so
like uh a lot of people are stubborn you
know not just all Tauruses
yeah great comment there uh possibly I
mean if you think the universe cares
about you enough to shape your your
personality I I don't know what else to
tell you because have you seen a picture
of how small Earth and the solar system
is in the galaxy to then proceed to
declare that something about this
universe cares about you and your
birthday this is ego gone a muck just
think about that how big an ego must you
have to say Mars is in the sky and this
it and I was born when that happened so
it is talking to me that's that's ego
for you I look at it a different way to
to say that I'm actually more special
than to be lumped in with every [__]
who happens to share my
birthday you know like just like if
somebody says dude we have the same
birthday it's like okay that is where
our similarities end because like I like
you know I'm I'm a rather particular
about a lot of things that's funny
what's the like is there any at the at
the heart of astrology that does make
sense right is it like based on gravity
people always say like well the moon
affects the tides why wouldn't it affect
your mood like is where Mars is or where
Jupiter ising the but is there any is it
is at the heart of is there anything
where it actually I mean thee are we
[__] when Mercury is in retrograde so
here's the thing let me give an
exposition on Mercury in retrograde just
for a moment just take a moment okay
um are if you believe you're in the
center of the
universe and you watch Mercury move
against the background stars and then
slow
down stop and then start moving in the
opposite direction you're going to come
up with a word for that because that's
weird Behavior you're in the center and
somehow it is not continuing its path
around you so you come up with the word
retrograde it's a word to describe what
you
see now uh once we learn we are not in
the center of the
universe the sun is in the center of the
solar system not we and we orbit the
sun then this movement of mercury
becomes very obvious to understand it's
closer to the Sun than us it moves
faster around the Sun than we do so
sometimes you'll see it passing left to
right as it comes in front of the Sun
and then from right to left as it goes
to the other side when you're at if
you're at a NASCAR race and the car goes
by you right in front of you when it's
going the other direction on the other
side of the track you're not saying the
cars just went into
retrograde no you're saying it's it's in
One Direction around the track you're
not thinking to yourself the car is
moving backwards because it's not it's
always going forwards that's how big the
ego must be for you to think that the
movement of other objects in the
universe is backwards that's that's ego
run a muck um I think and you asked
about grab so the
Moon uh so the tides rise and fall this
sort of thing right right
um so the strength of the
tides this is a weird thing and you're
going to wonder what the hell who did
you invite into this interview well we
invited you I'm
excited uh
so the moon the strength of the tides
that the moon creates on Earth is
basically the same no matter the time of
day or day of mind
okay um what happens is The Sun Also
creates
Tides if the sun's Tides add directly to
the moon's Tides you get higher high
tides okay and when it's like at right
angles to it it tamps down the moon's
high tides and you get what they call
neep Tides okay because the tides are
getting pulled sort of in both
directions both exactly exactly
so my point point is when you say oh the
full moon made extra high tides no it's
because when you have a full moon the
sun's Tides add directly to
it so when you say the moon full no the
the Gravity from the Moon is the same on
you every day of the month every day of
the month doesn't matter what phase it
is at all and so it's all about the Sun
but nobody talks about it that way right
because they want the moon to be the
thing that's doing the thing but it's
not then why it's a subtle but a very
important point but okay so why when you
go to like any of these beaches around
here uh high tide low tide it's six foot
you know
minus okay but then when you go to like
the Philippines or like an island you
have boats that are just on dry land
because it's so tidal of a place oh yeah
it depends on the slope of the shoreline
going from the ocean to so you go to the
Bay of Fundy yeah which has the
Ferocious Tides all right so what
there's a there's a bay that channels
water inland and as The Tide Rises if
the Tide Rises a
foot but one foot higher than where you
are is a half a mile up the bay mhm then
that water is going to be racing up the
bay that makes sense to reach that extra
foot so there places on Earth where the
tides just look completely
ferocious and so so yeah and the Bay of
funing oh there's another thing This Ti
you didn't ask this but I'll tell you
since we're there the Bay of bay ofun
and other places where the tides are
ferocious against the shores um it's
actually slowing down the rotation of
the earth we've had 23 24 leap seconds
added just because of this phenomenon
since the early 197 why because the
water's so heavy the water's sloshing so
the Earth is turning again oh I I I
should have made this clear if you're
sitting on the beach and you so the tide
is coming in and out that's not what
it's doing that's what it looks like to
you because you have a earth human ego
because everything is about you okay
what's actually happening is the tidal
bulge of the ocean is there fixed in
space with respect to the Moon okay it's
just there and Earth is spinning inside
of that title bulge so what's happening
is you are turning into the high tide
and coming out of the high
tide it the tide is not coming towards
you or back away from you but it's
described that way because that's what
it looks like
because we still we still retain some
prec capern vocabulary we don't say uh
at what time does Earth rotate such that
the Sun appears over our Horizon we say
what time does the sun rise okay that's
an earth Centric word we're not giving
up on it because it's too too easy to
use and we all understand and and what
was
cernus uh famous for he put Earth back
in the center of the known universe yeah
with so Earth then became a planet after
that okay whereas before then again this
is kind of inside baseball here you I
don't know if you wanted to go so before
cernus there were seven planets Mercury
Venus Mars Jupiter Saturn the Sun and
the Moon oh and you're not counting
Pluto we're getting out of this world
people which makes it so fitting that
this episode is brought to you by
Miracle made sheets which uses nasau
Tech technology to make sure that 99% of
bacteria cannot live on the sheets and
they're totally temperature cooled tell
you right here in my edit Bay I've got
the pull out sofa and my guests are
raving about the sheets they they won't
leave I'm like get out of here come on
we got to work but everybody loves
Miracle ma sheets and so do I and if you
want to get Miracle M sheets
Plus a free three towel set and more
than 40% off then it's time to go to try
miracle.com
sto and use the promo code steo you got
to see what I'm talking about these are
the most comfortable Cooling and
bacteria free sheets in the world it's
try miracle.com
ssto now let's get back to it
this way before Pluto got discovered and
undis and un and demoted right okay so a
planet planetes in the Greek means
Wanderer so there were seven objects
visible to the uned eye pre- telescope
that moved against the background
Stars Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter Saturn
the Sun and the Moon our seven days of
the week owe their
names to those objects wow guess what
Sunday is named after
wow
Pluto guess what Saturday is named after
okay Saturn okay now now these what's
Tuesday uh so Tuesday is um well so what
is do you know what it is in Spanish or
in a romance language ah mirac martes
martes it's named after Mars and and T's
Mars is the god of war and Tes in Norse
Legends is their God of War so it still
corresponds even though we're hybridized
from just ordinary Roman names to Latin
American uh I mean so Roman names and
Norse names so uh
Thursday is Thor's day okay and he
wields the lightning bolt well who
wields the lightning bolt in Roman
Legends Zeus Zeus No Zeus is Greek yes
and his car he's that's all I
got half credit um Zeus Wheels lightning
bolt in the Greek Legends the
corresponding God to him later in Roman
is Jupiter Jupiter and what is Thursday
in Romance languages hesz so that's
that's Jupiter with a J Wow Paul's
winning all the awards yes he
is okay so um so this these seven
planets are deep in our culture when
cernus says earth goes around the Sun
the moment he did that we became a
planet and the Moon is no longer a
planet cuz it just orbits
us okay and so the planet count went
from seven down to six because we gained
Earth and lost the no we yeah did I to
say that right gained Earth lost the
moon well then it would stay the same
and then we lose the Sun ah so that so
it was down to six yeah right okay and
then we discovered other planets with
telescopes Pluto came in had a 60-year
Tour of Duty then we kicked it out you
kicked it out I was an accessory to
the
accessory to the
murder okay I didn't I definitely drove
the getaway car but I didn't that's all
you going to tell me here um Okay I uh
speaking of ancient beliefs right I I
want many and ask yourself what beliefs
do we have today which in 200 years will
be viewed as ancient but go on stay
about this that's exactly where I'm
headed to good okay um I was once many
many years ago smoking a bunch of
marijuana and I had this deep thought
but does marijuana come in bunches is
that is that the proper term it's not a
herd of
marijuana block of marijuana is it a
what is the term for okay you're right
it was a
gang um so I I had this thought man that
while you were smoking marij yeah just
in in this in this state of mind in this
state of mind and I thought uh wow you
know people um used to gen genuinely be
afraid of of riding their sailboats when
they first invented sailboats they were
scared to ride them too far for fear
that they might fall off the end of the
world because the belief was that the
world was
flat then no no you can have an infinite
Flat Earth so it's not only that it was
flat but it had an edge okay okay a flat
disc a circular disc right there you go
you look at old maps in the Vatican pre
Columbus so pre-colombian Maps there
they are with Jerusalem in the center
cuz we put ourselves in the center at
all times there is Jerusalem the Holy
Land in the center and it goes out to
the edge and there's water around the
edge and there demons at you know there
be demons or or or or monsters at the
edge and so it's a scary Edge there yeah
there it was okay so then we we um
developed enough uh understanding to uh
come to the belief that the world is
Round And as such you cannot fall off
the end of Earth I wouldn't I would call
The Flat Earth a Bel belief and the
round earth a fact
okay you heard it here first folks can
we can we use proper terms here okay all
right so wear it's not that we believe
Earth is
fear okay
so tell you you will be healed if you
believe when you have evidence you don't
you no longer need to invoke the word
believe okay we learned that the that
the world is Round And as said she
cannot fall off the end of it I then
thought man when are we going to
discover the fact that you also cannot
fall off of the end of time time is
round
dude that's what you said okay that
would be a
belief it would be kind of cool if a
Time looped back that would surely be
the case if the expanding universe one
day slowed down
reversed collapsed and then started in
another big bang right okay then the
Edge of Time Is there an edge of time
well there's the beginning of time and
the End of Time showing up in the same
spot see so that would be kind of deep
so smoke a few more joints and pick up
the thought can you imagine if he was
like I've never thought about that
before and you were on to something and
you w the Nobel Peace Prize or
something right I mean just the idea
that time
um has a beginning and an end that it's
linear I think well it's not it's not
linear because we know time could be
different for different people depending
on how fast you move and where you are
in the universe we known that from
Einstein's relativity relativity so I
guess it's linear for you but compare
all different time frames like if you're
accelerating time moves very differently
for you well can you can you explain how
what uh how they measure time it's an
atom that blinks a billion times in a
certain amount of time and that equals a
second oh is right okay okay we can go
there you ready yeah okay time the the
length of a second up until the 50s or
60s I think it was early 1960s was
defined by a specific fraction of the
duration of the year
1900 for for laboratory
purposes and okay well that's that the
year divides up into days and then
there's hours and minutes and seconds
and the rotating Earth is at the base of
that as is is one of the is is is a is a
key part of this measurement
okay then they said well well let me ask
you if Earth in a 24-hour day is your
measure then how do you measure whether
Earth's rotation
changes
the sun you can't oh that's if your
measure of time is based on the rotation
of the earth and the time it takes Earth
to go around the Sun if those things
change you will never know that because
that is your that is your yard stick
yeah if your yard stick is changing you
will only know that if you have another
yard stick to compare it to okay okay wa
hang on so we offloaded the measurement
of the duration of a second to Atomic
vibrations the cium atom you might have
heard cium 137 I think it so there's a
transition what we call an electronic
transition in the cium atom that gives
off that that where you can measure the
vibrations of that in the laboratory and
the duration of a second was defined and
it has been defined that way for the
past 60 years when we did
that when we did that we said hey Earth
is slowing down
we for the first time we could just
measure that Earth is slowing down the
rotation is the rotation of the earth is
slowing down back to the Bay of fundi
and the tides oh not only that
earthquakes can change the rotation rate
of the earth and melting glaciers
because it changes where the mass is on
the earth it's no different from a
skater who's spinning and then they
bring in their arms and they spin faster
yeah do they have retro Rockets or
something to no they changed where the
mass was in their rotating body and it
affected the rate at which they rotated
if you have earthquakes they can shift
plates continental plates to different
parts of where Earth is affecting our
Rotation by a very tiny amount of course
migrating animals from north to south
South Beth and North also effect but the
biggest effect is the tidal sloshing on
our Shores so only then could we measure
yeah and we put in 23 24 leap seconds
since then if so all of that you you
started this by asking me about the
length of a second yes it is a vibration
of an atom yes to this day if the so as
polar ice caps melt and there's more
water we're going to slow down even more
yes only because only because the water
that's in the
poles as that melts it goes back into
the ocean yeah the ocean levels rise
that's one factor yeah but it goes into
the ocean and that water can move now to
the Equator so that's Mass
going away from the rotation axis so if
you ever see skaters they bring in their
arms they spin faster and then the
routine ends well how do they stop
spinning you don't know this but they
return their arms to an outer outer
position this slows down their rotation
it looks like they're just posing for
the photo but if they didn't do that
they would keep spinning
forever no but well will the Earth ever
stop spinning then it's a great question
and if the Earth stops spinning where is
it going to land sadly that's just not
something you can bet on at this time
but UFC 294 sure is and UFC's official
partner draft King Sportsbook has the
offer of the century for you guys if you
download the draft King Sportsbook app
and use the promo code steo a mere bet
of $5 gets you instantly two $200 in
bonus bets I mean you're winning big out
of the gate and that's why we love it if
you're going to bet on the UFC anyway I
mean if that's your thing then you're
out of your mind if you don't download
the draft King Sportsbook app and use
the promo code steo to get a $200 in
bonus bets for just putting down five
bucks and dude this card's going to be
insane it was supposed to be like the
main event and the co-main event were
different they lost fighters to injuries
and The Replacements make the fights way
better oh man I can't wait neither can
you download draftking sports book and
use the promo code steo gambling problem
call one800 Gambler or visit www.1 1800
gambler. net in New York call 8778 Hope
and Y or text Hope and Y to 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 789 7777 or
visit ccpg dog please play responsibly
on behalf of booill Casino and Resort KS
liy partner Golden Nugget Lake Charles
La 21 plus age varies by jurisdiction
void in Ontario bonus bets expire 168
hours after issuance C Sports book.
draftkings.com MMA terms for eligibility
and deposit restrictions terms and
responsible gaming resources now let's
get back to it no so these forces acting
on the earth yeah
um yeah I mean 7 to 10 billion years
it's slow so the sun is long dead by now
okay so this is a this is just just a a
a theoretical exercise yeah so
um so this the Moon is slowing down
Earth and it will do so until we only
show one face of Earth to the Moon right
we did that to the Moon we slowed down
the moon's rotation so it only shows one
face to us that's why there's a near
Side of the Moon and a Far Side of the
Moon there's not a dark side by the way
all sides get sunlight like a month is a
day on the moon all sides get we never
see it yeah it's just away from you so
must be dark just cuz you don't see it
you think there's no like the sun don't
shine there no okay again that's our ego
just check your ego at the door before
you contemplate the cosmos okay and
that's why the aliens have a base on the
Dark Side of the Moon yes EX on The Far
Side of the Moon Yeah so we can't see
them except we have orbiting craft
around the moon so we we we got that all
right if they're hiding it but wait so
so by the way does he always have this
face blowing his a oh there's an
astonishment like the first time he just
got laid he's
like I'm fascinated I'm definitely fasc
so so so we got we got a lot of
astrophysics in the last 10 minutes
going there okay so um so while you were
getting high let me just say that the
brain barely
works as it is barely we know this from
py ology experiments you know two people
witness some astonishing thing in front
of them they have to write down what
they saw and the the accounts don't
agree which is why if you're witness to
a crime and crime is not an everyday
thing you don't your your brain can't
know even know how to process it you're
saying we only use like 7% of her brain
no no that's a that's never been a true
fact oh okay six no that's that's a a
falsely
interpreted understanding of someone's
comment who studied the brain like 100
years ago I forgot who it was but it was
it it might even be apocryphal but the
the statement was the brain is so
complex we only know what 7% of it is
used for mhm that became you only use 7%
of your brain and because that's a
teacher's mantra for underperforming
students to try to rec recover brain
power that's not going to ever go away
it's too useful in the in educational
circles have we made any uh oh I don't
finish so your brain barely works you
you've seen um these books of uh what do
you call it with the um Ro Shack no no
keep going one more no one more one more
um Optical optical illusions we no one
doesn't love an optical illusion book we
love them but wait a minute these are
simple line drawings simple is one line
longer than the other I can't tell is it
in the page out of the page oh my gosh
the simplest illustrations can
completely stump your P perceptions okay
that's a fully functioning working brain
all right so
now stir in some chemicals yeah okay so
so what I'm saying is the people who
declare that they are somehow closer to
reality when they are under the
influence I have yet to see that bear
out in any objectively true
way I so I value
that what I see and understand and
interpret in the
world is the reality as best as my
senses can interpret and so to say well
let's just add some more chemicals and
see what it turns out um you know I I'm
just saying but the ability of your
brain and your eyes to absorb everything
is limited that we know right well some
people are better at it than others but
yes yes or I would say it differently
there are things you notice
subconsciously that you don't notice
consciously there's some fascinating
experiments on that one so I would say
the opposite that you you aware of more
than you are than you are consciously
think you are right because it's it's
sort of that like cocktail hour effect
like you you eliminate a lot of so much
information is coming in you're you're
eliminating most of it you focus it Down
Right anybody know the cocktail party
effect no all your uh inhibition it's
just like in a room of a lot of people
talking you can listen to one person and
you're so you're deleting like 95% of
audio coming you know how to do that
most effectively okay cuz you're
deleting let's say it's just a regular
party yeah and everyone speaking English
you're deleting other people speaking
English to listen to the person in front
of you who's speaking English some of
whose words will be exactly the same as
what you're deleting that's a harder
task than if you
multilingual just speaking another
language to your person and the the
channels go wide open especially if the
other language has very different dip
thongs what's a dip thong I I think I
know what a dip thong is it's just
dialect thong are the sounds you make to
pronounce the words in your language
okay okay okay um different from a
[__] that's a not to be confused you
okay I'm I'm going to switch gears here
yeah please please I don't want to
derail where I want be your servant I'm
a servant of your curiosity I'm very
you're a curious guy I'm very curious
I'm very interested as long as you don't
make me jump out of airplanes
flight you bet total respect I've never
broken a bone and I don't want this to
be the first day that happen I love that
um I I I I I imagine that you might be
incredibly
uh opposed or offended by the idea of
what's called
biocentrism are you familiar with the
concept I I might be but tell me okay
this is the idea
that Consciousness is not um created by
the universe but rather the universe is
created by Consciousness oh okay sure
and the the the the the kind of
rationale for it is is to say logically
speaking does it make sense that such an
expansive universe that goes on forever
and ever and
ever and it doesn't Harbor life except
in this one Place Earth and it's like or
does it make more sense that our that
that Consciousness actually either
projects or or creates the this whole
yeah why you giving me only two choices
the third choice is there's life
everywhere and we're just on one one
planet you didn't give me that option
but that's the option I'm taking okay
all right now now the it would be weird
if this whole universe was there and we
were the only conscious life so I
understand why you can arrive at the
thought that our Consciousness creates
the universe that's once again the ego
talking okay um now hit me with your
take on oh by the way does the
Consciousness create what my telescope
sees when you didn't even know it was
there I think that Collective
Consciousness could be like a no because
everybody's going to see the same thing
at the
telescope but don't we all have
different independent
consciouses so that that means we're all
agreeing what our Collective
Consciousness should give that that's a
bigger you're you're
stretching The credibility of this
argument every Next Step that I'm taking
you I'm so so if you go to The Far Side
of the Moon and sketch what's there and
you go to the far side and if those two
sketches agree are they extensions of
your independent
consciousnesses are they or isn't an
objective truth that exists outside of
your conscious and that's what science
does it says I don't trust your
conscience I don't trust you you could
be on drugs you didn't have your coffee
this morning you you're you're grumpy
today so let's build an apparatus that
makes the measurement it's funny how you
pointed the Paul and said you could be
on
drugs how do you do that go there I did
point there not not not I what about the
double slit experiment where matter uh
is affected by
observation you it kind of feels like
you're speaking in a different language
when you're talking to this guy but I
don't even know if he speaks another
language other than English so maybe
he's
not like not that smart after all you
know because really smart people speak
more than one language and let me tell
you about a way to learn a second
language and be speaking it in as little
as three weeks it's called Babble baby
babel.com that's b a
bb.
and if you go to babel.com
steo you get
55% off your subscription and this
subscription is a hoot it's like you're
learning Spanish playing a fun video
game on your phone I mean it's like you
don't even want to stop and if you go
like 15 hours on this app is the same as
an entire University course teaching you
a foreign language telling you the
results are insane
and you could arguably say that you're
smarter than Neil degrass Tyson if you
speak more than one language so get on
over to babel.com sto to get
55% off your subscription that's
babel.com steo now let's get back to it
yes so it's not really it's not okay
well well sorry let me back up okay okay
that experiment is widely
misunderstood all right I would love to
to to get it straight here we're
straightening this out yeah be very
happy to wait where where's Wendy going
she she does that a lot she hates the
double slit
experiment yeah if she has to hear
another thing about the Double SL us
with our with her presence and and then
she dips out that's it's very routine
you know the first Wendy in literature
uh Peter Pan Peter Pan very good wow
they made up the name for that first
well it might preexisted but it wasn't
written down before that it's kind of uh
serendipitous because I found her in the
streets of Peru and swooped her up into
this like Fantastical world of Hollywood
yeah yeah and she went in an airplane
yep that's exactly right Trans
Continental dog just uh like kind of
like Peter Pan stole Wendy from uh from
from her from her life and whisked her
away to this crazy Place do they ever
establish the gender of Peter I guess
Peter's a boy name so Peter's a boy but
he was often played by played by small
girls right but that was just for the
small part because they needed to Hoist
the the person around the theater and
fly them well they're heavy women too
but just yeah
okay no you can get an adult small woman
playing the maturity necessary to be
Peter I think that was I think I think
the is understood that Peter was a uh a
male male male finger yeah okay so so
we're going to clean up the double slit
experiment yeah yeah so uh this whole
idea the observer effect where if you're
not looking at it you get one result but
if you look at it you get another result
particle yes and then people
overinterpreted that as though your
Consciousness is affecting the
experiment these tend to be people who
are new age leaning people who want to
think that science and its
objectivity somehow does not have full
access to all of nature that there's got
to be some spiritual Dimension to to it
that's outside the reach of Science and
Consciousness right now is not a fully
understand understood construct so it
leaves it open to in to to invoke it
okay so here's what's going
on we are illuminated by lights in this
space right now yep that's how I can see
you're there yeah the light is coming
from the bulb reflecting off of you
entering my retina going to my brain I
do not imagine that you're there cuz I
can demonstrate your existence by other
means so no that I'm not being bioc
Centrist here if that's how you define
biocentric so um let's say you were
smaller okay you half the size same
effect let's keep making you smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller there is
a size below which when I turn on that
light you will absorb that light and
jump to another state of
existence so that how do I know you're
here I turn on the lights but if you're
an
electron and I can't I don't know that
you're there I can't see you let me turn
on the lights I turn on the lights the
beam the the photon hits the electron
the electron jumps to a different
state I cannot know what the electron is
doing unless I illuminate it and if I
illuminate it it's doing something
different from what it was before I
illuminated it it has nothing to do with
Consciousness it has to do with
interacting with the object in order to
make a measurement and that requires
some way to illuminate it to know that
it's there so in the double slit where
you're it's like sending particles or
something through these slits the very
Act of once you measure it because
you're not just observing it with your
eyes you're measuring it with a tool
that tool the measurement of that tool
is what changes the correct it's not
your eyes it's not your brain it's the
fact that you have an apparatus brought
to bear on it and then you'll see
particles go through either one slit or
the other they they become particles and
do that if you take that away they
interact as waves and then you get the
interference patterns I like how Paul
knew it like he actually went to school
I me you just
did huh need physics 104 for that one um
oh not just 101 I get it
okay I picked up on
it so I haven't broken any yet in your
presence here yeah you've not broken any
bones um so simulation
theory was that a question does
it um does simulation Theory um is is
there this is just new wage cooks that
are just rejecting science no no there's
there isn't a strong argument against it
so it persists okay I I I try to work on
some arguments that mitigate it
but uh so do people know the full
argument that supports it it goes
something like this um you develop the
power the computing power to create a
simulation in the computer you create
people with
personalities uh and they those people
think they're making decisions out of
free will even though you programmed it
but they think it's free will
all right so then they say all right we
want to play games too so they well they
want to play games at all so they invent
computers and then they invent a world
in their computers that they
simulate and then that world invents a
world that they
simulate
so in this construct there's one real
world and all the world's derivative of
that are
simulated so now close your eyes and
throw a dart which world are you most
likely to
hit not the first one not the first
one is is is he the only one paying
attention to what I'm saying I'm trying
my ass with you you asked the damn
question I'm watch it's just okay okay
so
so the statistics of it are such
that if that's going on at all we're
probably in one of these simulated
universes okay just by the just by the
sheer numbers of it okay so my rebuttal
to that now there there are nuances you
can invoke here like okay um maybe they
like simulating worlds that don't have
the ability to create a perfect
simulation okay so these would be worlds
that are just
nostalgic like think of movies in a way
those are simulation aren't
they do you know how many movies are
made that were made before we could make
movies sorry I didn't say that right do
you know how many movies are made set in
an era before we could make movies do
you know how many what fraction um
probably 60% no no vanishingly small
like cowboy western yeah one less than
1% something something like it's a very
I mean think about it Scott very I am
right now very tiny percent so in the
age of movies we make movies in times
when we could make movies yeah right
okay yeah all right so are the simulated
universes making universes only in the
time when they can make universes oh my
God okay if
so then this is a rapid thing where
they're all but we could be just my
point is we could be a side branch we
could be like the Western the side
branch where they just don't know how to
make a perfect Universe yet yeah and
they're happy with that and we'd still
be simulated because that's the rebuttal
to my only rebuttal which is if the
first one knows how to make a perfect
universe and all the rest are
simulated then the only other one that
doesn't know how to make a perfect
universe is the last one that's still
evolving
computers well that's kind of like us
it's very viable do you have a rebuttal
for people who believe in
reincarnation yeah there's well I I
don't want to say it's not happening all
I can say that is that there's no good
evidence for it and so you can run
around believing things for which
there's no evidence most of that is
called religion okay so so I would push
back on that I think that there is push
back on what I I would push back on the
the statement that there's no evidence
of reincarnation oh what's your what's
your single best evidence of
reincarnation got one please please tell
me there's that girl that when she first
was able to start speaking
she went like told her family that she
died in a past life they went to the
Philippines they found where her body
was dug up and uh they ended up
arresting the guy that she found in her
Village that killed
her that's interesting I heard about a
lot of people so so so so
um is there any other way that could
have happened other than that she was
reincarnated defying all known laws of
physics is there a possible way that
could have happened or she's really
lucky well that's what I'm saying how
many crimes are committed in a year how
many people are murdered how many people
give hints that they don't know they're
giving hints how many people I mean so
so it's you've got to really be
convincing MH relative to all other
possible explanation for what's going on
there then I would say uh many by the
way reincarnation is a fundamental
tendent of Hinduism so you those
examples should be everywhere they
should be there should be Mill excuse me
a billion of those examples you can draw
upon I have a theory that like your your
birth mark wait how many Hindus are
there in the world uh that that I don't
India has 1.4 billion people so if if
most of them are Hindu a billion yeah
it's a billion is probably the right
number we're about to find out right
here i' say it's a billion yeah I have a
theory that like your birth mark or
beauty mark is one billion is how you a
billion yeah so so mostly in India of
course so and the indiaan Das diaspora
so I'm just
saying um I I've got one for you uh so
I'm at home and I go to sleep and wake
up and there's like milk and cookies on
the table I said well how did that get
there oh it must be someone transported
inter dimensionally entered my home
baked the cookies and put it on my shelf
or aliens brought it or my reincarnated
self brought it or someone who has keys
to my house who has affection for me
made me milk and cookies you know pick
you know what is your rank the
likelihood of explanations based on what
we know of objective
reality even even if kids are recogn an
extraordinary story that you just told
with with the with the girl and the
murderer in the body and so I would just
wonder if
reincarnation was the most likely
explanation for that and often when
people want to believe something they're
not as good as filtering the things that
could argue against it and it's it's
just a bias we have confirmation bias
yeah exactly like how often do kids say
things that are just just completely
ridiculous and aren't true and like what
percent like of theid ridiculous might
be true without there being
I feel like it's ignoring if if you take
into account every ridiculous thing a
child has said that they say swear is
true but is actually just completely
ridiculous like you
have 100% of times kids have been
accurate you're saying like a clock is
right two times a day when it's broken
you still use
clocks but but I I I've heard of stories
of of children um you know 2 years old
like recognizing people in photos saying
oh that's like that's me and that's my
red car that I bought in you know like 2
years old yeah I mean talking children
at 2 years old like if not two like
whenever they're able to talk but say
like yesterday I punched a whale and he
flew to the moon and it's like oh like
that didn't happen for sure so just cuz
the kid said like you have to consider
every time a kid is wrong as much as
every time a kid is Right correct and
that's the full statistical portfolio of
what's going on right all right right
I'm I'm I uh that's what I'm so that's
what I'm saying so let's chalk this up
as evidence for reincarnation I don't
have a problem saying that um but I
would wonder whether a full analysis was
given for any other way that could have
been true which is how you have to do
any science experiment and if
reincarnation is as prevalent as those
who believe in it say it is it happen a
lot more why why don't we have many more
examples of it which then leads me to
think there must be some extraordinary
but not Supernatural explanation for
this there's also the possibility that
Scott's story just isn't
true I believe things on Tik Tok some
said it okay well Tik Tok is your Bible
yeah yeah well maybe maybe you can
debunk this thing I heard on Tik Tok too
is wait wait
out it's wait it's bad enough when
someone says not bad enough it's I'm I'm
Charmed when people say could you debunk
this is this debunk what I heard on the
internet okay I was used to that for
like the last 10 years and now you're
saying Tik Tok yeah this is your Source
well there's a story on Tik Tok about
the the blue houses in Hawaii that
didn't burn down and they said because
this certain kind of blue paint won't
burn and they had experiments done where
they were like lighting different colors
on fire have you heard this no can you
pull up the blue houses of like a wahoo
cuz they said wait wait is some of these
wait is going to take me to Tik Tok or
is it take me to like see these blue
umbrellas didn't burn because it's a
certain paint that doesn't burn Under
Fire the conspiracy theory is okay so it
wasn't just Tik Tok that you saw this I
saw the video on Tik Tok but there other
other sources the conspiracy theory is
that the Hawaii fires was actually
started by like a laser in space and
that if anything was blue it didn't burn
and like Oprah painted her roof blue
like months before it happened and so
that's at least that's the theory that
Scott's referring to can you show a
video of like it burning like the actual
the
just a question a question for you um
you do not know what blue items did burn
and are not visible to you as having
survived the fire
correct yeah okay true so you don't have
the Baseline statistic on what fraction
of all blue things burned you're looking
at what survived it assuming all blue
survived it so that's this is as if if
you approach something scientifically
you want to ask those questions and then
you say is there some common material
among the blue that is fire retardant of
those things that did survive and you
just ask this or you can say alien zap
laser Zapped I mean what what's your
first thought when you're confronting
something that's interesting or unusual
and if you're a trained scientist you
you have enough knowledge of the laws of
physics that you start there yeah that
those aren't your last resort they're
your first Resort well I just like to
believe things
I'm not a scientist okay I'm pretty into
believing things too okay so it's more
fun and it makes headlines more you know
so I get it I get
it but I'm not that into believing
global
warming you want to believe things not
global warming okay yeah global warming
is not convenient did Oprah say why she
painted her house blue well there's a
bunch of celebrities that painted their
house blue did you say why uh no okay
cool just the blue conspiracy it's it's
like and you see a laser on different
colors and the blue just doesn't
burn okay it's a certain panone of blue
I don't even know if panon is the right
word uhhuh but uh yeah yeah I mean
there's all sorts of stuff on that's
cool I like it so I like so here's
here's what all conspiracy theories have
in common did you ever ask yourself this
they're all started by a
they're all
[__] no here's what they have in
common you ready every single one of
them I've yet to find an exception to
this um there are
people who are sure something is
true that they want to be
true okay yeah and they
find evidence in support of what they
want to be
true when an absence of
evidence that should be there and
isn't or if there's evidence that points
against
it they have to invoke a
conspiracy to keep believing what they
want and say the missing evidence was
taken by the government or this
conflicting evidence was put in by the
government to throw you off so that they
can continue to believe what they want
rather than have the gaps in the data
unravel what it is they think is true
well people don't like to say I don't
know I'd love to say I don't know I love
it you're smart oh no I don't know I I
love the universe brims with Mysteries
and all those UFO sighting I don't know
what they are I know what a lot of them
are I don't know what all of them are
let's investigate them yeah but if I'm
in an argument with somebody I don't say
I don't know I'm just like oh yeah and I
try to bend it to to win the argument
why do you have to win every argument
what what's wrong with you ego
based S no it's a sensitive ego it
sounds like I'm a sensient being he's a
real dip thong I didn't say sensient ego
I said sensitive ego yeah so so so yeah
I um you know so people come up to me
said uh well what was around before the
Big Bang what banged it's a great
question said I don't know we got top
people working on it something had to be
around I don't know something was there
God was there I said oh okay that's what
you require I'm telling you it's a
frontier
and just because there's a scientific
Frontier doesn't mean there's mythical
magical spiritual Divine forces
operating there just cuz we're not there
yet by the philosophers call that the
god of the gaps okay we can call it the
conspiracy of the gaps you need gaps in
the data in order for you to sustain the
the
accusation that what you believe is true
no matter what and what doesn't fit it
has been conspired against you um I
think that the answer to what was before
Big Bang lies in a a a definition of
space time that we uh are not equipped
to to compute well perhaps not but we
have top people working on it would you
have been
around 2,000 years ago to say these
planets they're going forward and then
backwards uh our mind is not equipped to
compute that in fact Claudius tmy
ad150 brilliant guy he bit on the wrong
horse he set up the geocentric system
bet on the wrong horse in the margin of
his notes he said when I trace at my
pleasure the windings to and mess up the
quote all right you're supposed to do
that after the quote than that's an
after the quote response okay when I
trace at my pleasure the windings to and
fro of the heaven bodies I no longer
touch Earth with my feet I stand in the
presence of Zeus himself and take my
fill of
Ambrosia oo and that is now react okay
yeah
oo that was less authentic by we just I
was reacting that way because I was like
oh that's the quote that you really
really prominently highlighted in your
new book oh you never noticed that oh
thank you yeah I absolutely noticed that
that's uh very clever segue too oh my
God a big
prominent to infinity and beyond yeah so
I'm just saying that quote is he was
feeling Divinity in that moment yeah
okay we call it mythology but it's his
religion if he's referencing Zeus that's
his God his main god and so he doesn't
have the answers he's just pawing at
them with Epic and all these sort of
constructs to try to understand how the
universe works so for you to
say before the big man maybe our B mind
just cannot cope with it if you've been
around throughout the history of time
you'd be at a hundred turns of our
understanding saying we just can't cope
with it but someone smarter than you
comes along and copes with it learns
about it figures it out and we move on
so stay out of the lab okay if that's
how you feel feel about things we don't
yet know in the universe stay out of the
line I I think what what was was going
more towards is that um the
the time isn't really a thing
dude well Einstein once said time is
defined to make motion look simple I
like that
okay I like that yeah it's good it's
good so so why do you want to say time
isn't a thing because it actually is
thing okay it's a coordinate here here
here here you go you ready I will
convince you ever more after this next
moment okay okay you ready yeah okay so
if I say oh we're such good
friends um
let I'll meet you tomorrow at 3:00 yeah
what's your next sentence to me well let
me check my calendar and see what's
going on at 3:00 tomorrow okay good so
nothing's going on then what um sounds
good bro let's do it no that's not what
you would say what would you say where
where oh yeah that's true [__] say where
okay Dimension okay wa no let's keep
going so I gave you only one coordinate
a time coordinate insufficient to
establish an intersection of two people
and they're called World lines when we
combine space and time so now I say um
dude I'll meet you in your mobile van
tomorrow okay yeah and you're gonna say
where do you want
it oh yeah what time what time what time
where do you want me to bring the van
and where where we know
intuitively that to meet up with
someone time and space are fundamental
coordinates you have to give them okay
you're not thinking about it that way
but they are all right what made coid so
interesting to me as a side light is
when with the rise of Zoom as means of
communicating with people it removed the
wear
coordinate from the need to meet up with
people you just had to be at the same
time you didn't have to be at the same
place the interwebs yeah it's true so
now what you're saying is but time's not
ACC coordinate there there are no Zoom
calls without time as a coordinate I'm
convinced forever more thank you you you
got me thank you I have a question about
the these
unknown gaps in our understanding of
things and astrophysics yeah there's
tons of them if if God was real and he
was going to give you a true
succinct that's not very PC of you but
go on okay and and you're assuming only
one God not multiple gods yes so you're
being West a thought experiment no but
but we just just to be clean and clear
okay most people in the world who
believe in God believe in more than one
God right so you're saying if God like
it's only one God so be very very
specific are we in the judeo-christian
tradition here in this conversation if
all yes good and if the single all
knowing god yes were to give you a
truthful succinct answer to one question
you can ask what what question would you
ask him it would be is the hum in the
line of what you were hinting at before
is the human mind capable of
understanding everything in your
creation I like it that's what I would
ask if the answer is yes I go back to
the science lab if it's no I I'll go to
the
Bahamas just take your head off I'm done
here I'm done here yeah okay can you
that's what I would ask cool so you just
want to know is is this is my knowledge
finite or no not knowledge my capacity
to figure thank the capacity for the
human the the wiring of the human brain
to so for example no matter how bad you
were in math in
school okay however bad you were at long
division you are infinitely better at it
than a
chimpanzee you are not teaching a
chimpanze long division ever right is
there something in the universe that
requires an understanding of math or
some even higher level thing that we
have yet to
Plum that will prevent us from truly
understanding the workings of nature I'd
want and then after that I would say if
you're
real why is the world so full of
evidence that you're
not
o that's a go be does that make you
that's what I would say does that make
you an atheist by definition I would say
um so I wouldn't mind being called an
atheist if I was not criticized by
atheists by some of the things I do ah
so the fact that I'm criticized okay I
gu I must not be an atheist then so I
guess agnostic would be the yeah the a
closer a more a softer term because
modern day atheists are like all up in
your face typic typically or the more
visible ones are and so for example I I
will defend AD and BC as the you know
the abbreviations for um in the year of
the Lord AD anodin and BC before Christ
I'll defend the use of those because a
lot of hard work went in to creating
that calendar the Gregorian calendar
which is now used worldwide that's a
it's based on a Christian construct but
it had a lot of very interesting science
that went in behind it I'm not just
going to swap out the words to Der
rigify it I don't mind leaving credit
where it's due and so that I don't know
any atheist that still uses AD and BC my
favorite era common era CE and BCE and
before Common Era but who are they
fooling it's the same numbers of year
they're they're just trying to whitewash
paint over a religious reference and I
don't have that much objection to the
religious participation in Civilization
it was fundamental so I don't I'm not
going to sweep it under the rug I have
an Absol and and okay one of my friends
went up on the space shuttle to fix the
Hubble and on my Facebook page I said
godp speed the space shuttle and someone
WR you said spe I thought you were an
atheist again these are the The Atheist
rebuttal to my conduct I thought you
were an atheist and why are you saying
God spe I say well have you ever used
the word goodbye well yeah of course
that comes from God be with you wow
where is that why because you'd be
leaving the city
walls just go back you know 700 years
you you're leaving the city walls that's
dangerous if if you did that in a
Christian world you would say God be
with you on your journey to the next
thing and so you wouldn't say goodbye to
people just leaving your home staying in
the city you would say it to people
going on a journey okay goodbye God be
with you to give you protection between
cities so God speed the thing that will
kill you in a rocket is speed okay not a
morer or a Mugger in space so you want
to protect them in the same Spirit as
you did with the God be with you turning
into goodbye so uh uh godspeed is the
space journey C journeyer counterpart to
that term and when John Glenn went into
space it was the headlines godspeed John
Glenn and it is
cultural as well as this bit of
religious historical Legacy in the space
community and whoever criticizing me for
using that didn't know any of that there
you go of course yeah screw those people
and my musical of all time on Broadway
grew up in New York City is Jesus Christ
Superstar all right oh my gosh that I'm
going to make an absolute statement my
favorite classical piece Coral piece is
box mass and B
minor okay just I'm just saying so I I'm
I'm I'm not one of these people running
around hitting religious people on the
head
okay maybe my absolute statement will
hit religious people on the head okay
what's that okay um I believe that the
only thing you can possibly be is
agnostic I think that it's actually
impossible to uh to because Faith people
of faith is the definition of faith not
belief in something which cannot be
proven no the definite faith is believe
in something for which there is no
evidence not that that it can't be
proven there people go back in time
where people made statements derived
from their religious text about the
physical world and we show that they
were demonstrably false there's no
reference in the Bible for example that
Earth isn't anywhere other than the
center of all motion okay the Bible does
not have an understanding that Earth
orbits the sun it had no understanding
of that that the moon reflects sunlight
it was believed to be it's it got a lot
wrong especially in Genesis where it's
setting up the universe so this thing
the proof or not I I don't think that's
what it's about it's
uh you know you have to believe that
Jesus rose from the dead you have to
believe that and um what's the
difference between cannot be proven and
there is no evidence
for uh I think it can be proven if you
make enough statements about what you
expect to be true if God
exists okay so for example so for
example um if you're at a plane at 5,000
ft and the wings break off and and it
falls okay if you on a religion where
you are sure it's the one true religion
which of course is the thinking in every
practically every religion that they are
the one true religion so let's take
Christianity because we're in the United
States here it's a common religion so
the Christians the one true religion the
Muslims the Jews the the Hindus the
atheists the animists they're all false
gods okay you're in you're in the plane
and the plane is about to crash all the
Christians pray for their own souls and
for The Souls of other Christians the
plane crashes the Christians walk away
and everyone else is dead oh my gosh
that's some remarkable evidence that
prayer works that Christianity is the
one true religion and the other ones are
false but when planes fall from 5,000 ft
everyone
dies there's plenty of ways I can think
of having EV evidence that your God is
the one true God and it does not exist
that's all I'm saying not in a
controlled laboratory sense right people
will testify that they had a Rel sure
that's in your own in yourself and in a
free country no one is going to take
that from you right I'm not going to
take it from you you're that's your
personal truth okay let's let's I let's
do this I declare that there are three
categories of truth there's your
personal truth God is uh Jesus is your
savior Muhammad is your last prophet on
Earth okay um the rivers and the
mountains and the streams is a spirit
energy that is God manifest in nature
okay that would be animism for example
okay that's your personal truth in the
United States of America that is
protected you cannot take that away okay
you cannot beat it out of you we're not
going to kill you imprison
you half or more of the immigrants that
came here was to to continue religious
freedoms that were being constrained
wherever they
were you know more recently I mean after
the big era of immigration Jews from
oppressed Europe where they were pers
come to the United States okay not that
it is perfect for everybody who's
different but the law protects you okay
so um so where why where was I going
personal truth that's personal Truth
Good another personal truth Beyonce is
your
queen
okay all right no one's going to take
that from you you could argue about it
at the bar whatever at the club but
that's your personal Truth All right so
you can have a political
truth that's something that becomes true
because of how frequently it has been
repeated and that's the foundations of
of brainwashing and and brainwashing and
propaganda
probably it's you have a truth because
you've been told it your whole life yeah
you are superior to everyone else you
are German in the third right and you
are superior okay that becomes true to
you and then the third true the
scientific truth so so the Third Kind Of
Truth oh another one is um uh you know
you hear Trump running against Hillary
anytime he mentioned her name he what
was what was the moniker crooked crooked
Hillary after a while he said oh crooked
must be your first name she must be cook
it it's repeated Enough by the way
there's important
evolutionary cause for
that when you're we're on the serengetti
and you see something
repeat you're going to believe that
that's true because it probably is true
because it repeats something happens in
nature that repeats well we created
civilization around us but we still have
that urge mhm to think that something
that repeats is true
so politicians and others who want to
influence you advertisers as
well have hijacked this evolutionary
urge deep within us they can make
anything make you think anything is
true even if it's not because your
evolutionary urge to think something
that repeats is true is tapped by that
effort okay that's a call that a
political truth then there's the
objective truths that the methods and
tools of science are exquisitly honed to
establish these are Truth by established
by multiple experiments verification
reverified but but the truths that are
that we find that are experimentally
verified they're not later shown to be
false so that there there's the
immutable laws of nature no I'm I don't
want to call them immutable because like
I said we might find a deeper
understanding Newton's Laws okay have
basically been replaced by Einstein's
relativity his special Theory relativity
for motion and his general theory
relativity for Gravity that was Newton's
contribution to us motion and gravity
his laws are Newton's are no longer
they're not where they were previously
used they still work we went to the Moon
with Apollo using Newton's laws but
there are places where Newton's Laws
fail because a broader Spate of
experimental evidence showed that at
high speeds and high gravity Newton's
Laws fail you need another understanding
a deeper understanding then came
Einstein so I don't want to call them
immutable okay but Newton's laws are
objectively true in all the Realms in
which they've been tested so that's why
I get to say science I mean that's the
full expression the bumper sticker
version is the good thing about science
that it's true whether or not you
believe in it it seems to me if we're
going to have laws that everyone has to
follow you should base them not on any
one person's religion or any one
person's propaganda you should base them
on objective truths that in fact apply
to us all I love it I love it man what
happened I just woke up okay how long
until we get did I put you to sleep no
you just blew my mind I just came back
to reality oh yeah I just like this is
what science and can I give an example
just just science just just let me just
flash some science at you please you you
read the news story I assume you did
because you you well I can't assume you
did you're up on on the Blue Roof
hypothesis okay did you catch the story
that we had a return sample from an
asteroid yeah I saw that okay osir about
ask how long until we get obliterated by
an as okay that's all you paid attention
to cation there's other news in there
too you ready here it is we launched a
spacecraft seven years ago from Earth a
moving
platform towards the asteroid benu a
Target we arrive
there it does a touch and go grabbing
material on that touch it it it packs it
into a
capsule that space probe
continues intersects Earth deploys the
capsule such that on the rotating Earth
it lands within a Zone in the Utah
desert and that spacecraft continues on
to another asteroid and that's what it
is programmed to do it's behaving as we
intended for it's called
science it's called Rockets yes as a
matter of fact it is rocket science we
did this we pulled this off yet there
are people walking Among Us say I don't
believe science science I don't trust
science do you see what it is we do
that's crazy do you have any
understanding of what this takes what
did you grab off the asteroid what it
was about we were ready to get just a
couple ounces but we got like a half a
pound of rock what kind of rock what
that we don't know we're going to find
out oh we have we have some idea of the
asteroid is made of from Spectra and and
external observations now we can compare
that to the laboratory measurements and
we share the samples with the world with
with with with interested other labs so
they can duplicate whatever it is I find
or falsify maybe I got the a wrong
result CU somebody sneezed on the sample
or the the wall current glitched you
never know so you get someone else to
repeat it so maybe something that it was
on there that's not on the periodic
table it's not likely it would be on the
periodic table because the periodic
table is
complete I don't know why chemists don't
champion this fact the first day of
school okay this will never change no no
I that's not what I said I said the
periodic table of elements is complete
there are no gaps and there were gaps in
it up until as late as the 60s 50s the
1950s there's some element here we don't
know what it is let's look for it okay
one of the last elements to be
discovered was
technum named Tech you know what the
definition of tech is
human-made wow that's why technology is
we made it it's not in nature okay tech
means it's taking on other other other
extra meaning in the ER of it and this
sort of thing but tech means artificial
human-made that element doesn't exist in
nature natural so we created it so but
that's not even weird because we got up
to right now we're up to so nature makes
elements up to
94 uranium plus occasionally up to uh
plutonium and in rare cases we have
created elements beyond that up to
118 so yeah there's gaps above 118 but
not in the main table that you saw
hanging in the front of your chemistry
class and the number the number is the
amount of protons in the the number of
protons correct so it's like we have one
with eight we have one with 10 but we
can't find the one with nine right we
find with n that's how you have Gap
that's how you know that there's a gap
CU it's a it's a discrete number of
protons in the nucleus of these atoms so
something come back could come back from
the asteroid that's 120 protons not
likely because that takes very high
energy to make but that would be an
element we have yet to create and
there'd have to be some mechanism in
nature to do that and we know of none
nor have we ever seen examples of it
nature takes us up to uranium 92 and
that's basically it so there's probably
gold on there oh uh not as likely there
are asteroids where that would
definitely be the case but it's harder
to do a touch and go because those are
metallic and the metal just doesn't
shatter when you do a touch and go this
is a rocky asteroid which was not held
together very strongly which we already
supposed was the case when you said that
um we've just gotten this material from
the asteroid and now we are going to
study it yes who's we well they're Labs
that that they're people who who
specialize in meteorites are you oh by
the way we expect to find organic
molecules on there too like stuff from
Whole Food and the organic aisle I
thought of that but yeah thank you
uh there like a grocery leafy vegetables
they're all there organically grown are
you going to be participating in the
studying no no no but my colleague I
have colleagues who who are who and so
so we look forward to this and there
might be even some amino acids which are
very simple organic mole molecules but
they're the building blocks of proteins
and proteins are the building blocks of
life why did you said it's a rocky
asteroid so you knew you were going to
to a rocky asteroid before you oh you
know that from its behavior and it's and
how light reflects off its surface how
many different kinds of asteroids are
there there many and I don't claim to
know the full catalog of them but for
but for this exercise let me just
declare there to be
two varieties there's a metallic
asteroid and a rocky asteroid why didn't
you go for the one with gold on it h
what you want to do is last Sue that and
bring the whole thing back yeah okay
there's enough gold on some of those
asteroids that it it exceeds the total
amount of gold that's ever been mined in
the history of the earth [__] right I
heard that so what you would do is you
would just collapse the gold market oh
don't do
that is it true that there's more gold
per square inch on a in a computer than
there is uh in a gold mine have you
heard that it depends on how they how
they soldered the the connectors cuz
they're all gold right I is it I don't
know gold is a very good conductor of
electricity so I I I don't know there
might be okay back on to asteroids but
it doesn't take much gold to get the job
done yeah okay that's why we have gold
uh Leaf um what do you call it when you
do that on a statue PL no no that
plating is not the right word that's too
that's too gilded gilded gilded you can
Guild with gold this guy's he's he's
this guy who is this guy he's the
gorgeous Paul brisy who's the guy he
just got sober like five he's a new
person I'm a new man he's a new man oh
because there's fewer chemicals
interfering with the limited ability
that any of wait wait wait you stopped
micro doing mushrooms I mean uh I
haven't in a while but I'm not I just
stopped smoking weed and I stopped
drinking how long's in a while few
months oh you haven't you haven't done
mushrooms in a in a few months oh oh
like a month for the mushroom he's
clearly the sharpest person in this van
right now okay I just want to say my
brain I don't mean to like diss the two
of you guys but my man here who're like
the guys in your class that s in the
back of the room in the back of the room
I was one of those as a student's like
teacher you didn't give us homework this
weekend love it and and he's the the
master Storyteller oh good he's uh like
he really um by the way stories don't
require objective truth they just
require imagination right and and my
only indictment of stirring chemicals in
was what it does to your access to what
is objectively true not what it might
otherwise do for you psychologically
emotionally uh and spiritually even of
course right okay back to asteroids I
didn't even know thanks for bring that's
an important I didn't want to I there's
a fuller story than what I began
describing right and it's really only
about what is objectively true that the
scientist cares about right we don't
want to um uh undermine or or uh
discount or or refute the um value of
somebody's I experience if it benefited
their life exactly exactly especially
with the micro doing experiments that
are being done today medically uh
there's quite a bit of future I think in
that I like that distinction and and
glad you brought up I I think he was
well um I didn't know that we take just
say
yes take credit you about asteroids
talking about I think I was I was
vaguely aware of uh you know the the
some uh matter from an asteroid or
something but it was from a very
separate uh source that I seem to recall
you stating as a fact that we are uh
have an asteroid coming toward us and
it's going to obliterate us is that
right 22 billion tons so so that same
asteroid where we obtained the sample
has an orbit that crosses Earth orbit
that's one of the reasons why it was
easy to get to to relative to much
farther asteroids in the asteroid belt
so uh by all calculations there's a one
at at this moment there's a one in
3,000 chance that it will collide with
Earth in the year
2182 it's about the size of a of a it's
500 meters across like the height of the
Empire State Building uh if you stood it
up next to it it would take out a county
but not it's not going to render anybody
it's not going to obliterate the Earth
well if it hit a city it would take out
the city for sure but no Earth will be
just fine but but we shouldn't speak of
it in those terms this is 160 years from
now let's build a defense system what
use this as an excuse to figure out how
to deflect it reliably yeah 160 years
that ought to be plenty of time to pull
that off you know if the
dinosaurs had a space program they'd
still be here cuz they would have
deflected the asteroid that took them
out right I I love that maybe you can
just keep taking pieces off of it till
it's not really a threat now like when
an asteroid hits the by the way this one
in 3000 that's because right
now it's not like it's headed towards
Earth in this moment everybody's an
orbit so you project the orbits into the
future right until one of those orbit
Crossings crosses the Earth because you
cross the street every day you're not
hit by a truck because your world lines
were different
when you're in the street you're in the
same place as the truck but at a
different time different time right okay
yes you you could be in the street at
the same time as the truck but you're
actually at a different place right okay
so we tried to disrupt the intersecting
World lines of the benu asteroid and um
which the likely of hit is 1 in 3,000 as
we get closer the orbital calculations
get more accurate so either the 1 in
3,000 will become 1 in 10,000 one in
100,000 or it'll become so there'll be a
point where it'll certainly hit us or it
certainly won't it's kind of but we're
not at that point yet it's like the the
uh the cone that indicates where the
Hurricane's going to go precisely good
man and you notice of course the closer
we are to the future date you're Pro ACC
the more accurate it is that's that's
all that's all we're talking about here
very good okay I want to good joke about
that okay he not entirely PC but it's a
good joke okay because these are
different hurricane models that make
different assumptions about them and you
follow them off into the into the
northern climbs okay and some of those
models were from Europe all right there
Europe has certain traditions and how
they model climate weat have and so
someone said uh when he was president
president Trump only got interested in
hurricanes and climate change when he
found out that involved European
models that's funny that's pretty that's
good that's a good
job I don't take credit for that I heard
that now we've kept you longer than we
normally keep anybody I my phone was
ringing somebody's trying to call me uh
I appreciate that so much yeah um if I
could and all my limbs are intact CU I
didn't know what you had in store for me
I do want to ask one last question yeah
wait I'm going to check my calendar here
make sure I'm okay the Gregorian
calendar what time we got here it's 2:30
234 oh [__] oh yeah uh I got to do a
phone call okay then I'll tell you what
I'll make a yes or no okay yeah go is
climate change real okay I have a I have
a better one I have a better yes or no
are we really in 2025 going to be
building a home on the
moon I I just saw that on the way here I
up they're going to be build houses on
the moon in 2025 all right I mean I
think the answer emis 3 is a return to
the Moon with astronauts that probably
will take place in 2025 and they have
some they might pitch tent but they're
not staying there they're coming back
okay okay by the way but you know the
moon do you really want to live there no
I mean plus you know food on the moon
would be really weird think about it if
you had a restaurant like Moon food but
maybe the food would be okay
but the restaurant would just have no
atmosphere
okay I set you up a bad a great finish
climate change is a rhetorical question
yes it's it's real um there's nothing we
can do about it we're screwed is that is
that a a yes no figure out a way to get
the CO2 out of the atmosphere you want
to say oh it's beyond our thought no get
smart people involved in it smart people
figure stuff out you know don't you know
the smart people always ridiculed in the
classroom right but where would
civilization be without them Paul okay
I'm not get on your phone call thank you
so
much you got it dude pleas meet you guys
that was so much fun if there's anything
we've got some time before we put that
there's anything you think of and you
want us to edit it oh no don't worry
about it no I'm all good but very
considerate of you dud great and there
you have it um I very subtly said at the
beginning of the show that I got a
little taste of my own medicine and it
felt good man if it felt good it just
feels good that I think um I think we're
getting good at doing this podcast thing
man I think we're getting a lot better I
think that the uh that the just the
whole thing man I just feel like we're
catching a Groove and and and I feel
like like the sky the limit baby because
we've got you guys the street team and
you're the ones who I love the most so
thank
you and thanks to outerknown for this
sick ass [__]
top Kelly Slater is my bro